on ne peut pas dire d'un côté je ne suis
pour rien dans fessenheim alors qu'il a
décidé de faire fermer fessenheim on
peut pas dire d'un côté nous avons
décidé de relancer le nucléaire alors
que la loi de programmation énergétique
prévoit encore de mémoire la fermeture
de deux réacteurs nucléaires ceux qui se
plaignent des conséquences sont ceux qui
chérissent les causes de ses
conséquences et ça ce n'est plus
possible le un moment donné vous
rappelez des écrits j'ai produit il ya
trois ans il ya quatre ans il des
sénateurs nous sophie primas qui avait
évoqué les trous énergétique que l'on
aurait souvenez-vous le les premières
faiblesses énergétique elle arrive bien
avant la guerre en ukraine
si vous voulez c'est pas moi de lancer
d'autres kiki mots qui m'ont éclairé
sans faire de mauvais jeu de mots mais
le nom ne peut pas passer notre temps à
être dans l'urgence politique alors oui
il ya urgence on va pratiquer la
sobriété entendait les allons également
faire des conneries et les nous sommes
en guerre mais si vous voulez c'est de
la dramatisation de lucidité aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui dialectique là elle elle
énerve les âmes est elle crée de
l'incivisme on ne peut pas passer notre
temps à nous dire qu'on est en guerre
quand on n'est pas en guerre la guerre c
c'est une politique avec un ennemi
là en fait on est dans nos échecs on a
affaibli la souveraineté de la france et
donc il faut quand même le rappeler ce
qu'ils nous disent aujourd'hui avec
beaucoup de moraline qu'il faut
faire attention à ce qu'on consomme etc
sont ceux qui ont qui ont qui ont
détruit une oeuvre qui datait du général
de gaulle poursuivi par tous ses
successeurs